vous avez et droit vous avez aussi des
devoirs si l'état vous épaulent dans
votre quotidien parce que vous n'y
arrivez pas vous avez en regard la
nécessité de porter une attention sur
votre enfant et si vous ne faites pas
par négligence ou par complicité toutes
les situations existent dans notre pays
on connaît des parents recéleurs on
connaît des parents qui ferme les yeux
on connaît des parents négligents on
connaît des parents extraordinaire mais
si vous ne le faites pas si vous
n'assumez pas cette fonction alors oui
vous devez être sanctionné la sanction
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas que financière
on parle toujours évidemment des
allocations familiales
bien sûr et d'ailleurs les allocations
familiales on peut les supprimer
totalement partiellement uniquement
confirmant le cas de l'enfant
délinquants de façon provisoire de façon
définitive et une graduation et ce je
pense aussi ce qui manque souvent mais
il peut y avoir d'autres formes de
sanctions
la déchéance de l'autorité parentale
c'est très fort mais je pense que pour
un parent qui ne s'en sort pas qui ferme
les yeux sur la délinquance de ces
enfants qui refusent d'assumer sa
mission de parents quand on est parent
on a des devoirs et des responsabilités
qui ne s'en sort pas il peut y avoir
autre chose que simplement effectivement
des conséquences financières
on peut sanctionner autrement que
financièrement mais je pense que la
sanction financière
aujourd'hui elle doit être tentés on n'a
jamais essayé mais on va examiner toutes
les formes de sanctions monsieur traoré
vous vous répondez non et je vais vous
poser une question à ce direct brut 1 et
est ce que vous nous aviez ce
comportement de jeunes délinquants
ça aurait changé quelque chose à votre
trajectoire que vos parents soient
sanctionnés non mais tout du tout
personnellement serait inchangée savait
déjà à l'époque
moi quand j'étais dans les jeunes
délinquants mineurs forcément j'étais d
un peu conscients mais jamais cherché
quelque part et j'avais le désir de
réussir je voyais mes copains autour de
moi des camarades savez dans les
quartiers c'est compliqué socialement
c'est compliqué et aussi et à tourner à
tous un rôle à jouer dans ces problèmes
là ne faut pas dire va sanctionner les
parents ça sera une des solutions je
pense qu'on le doit chercher des
solutions ailleurs vous savez
aujourd'hui des parents à l'époque moi
mes parents qui me permette à l'époque
il n'avait pas les quick est aujourd'hui
que les parents d'aujourd'hui sont
aujourd'hui mes parents à l'époque mes
parents ne faisait pas mes devoirs et
mam n'est pas au sport
voyez ce que je veux dire j'étais livré
à moi-même et on a une on est dans une
société où il ya des devoirs l'enfer
douala l'école quand vous regardez le
temps on passe beaucoup plus de temps
dehors qu'avec nos familles
personnellement tu vas arriver
soir chez toi aujourd'hui avec le monde
qui nous entoure c'est à dire l'heure de
l'informatique large information à la
fois des informations aujourd'hui il ya
des enfants qui arrivent leur port l on
prend connaissance des réseaux sociaux
comme les jeunes parents qu'ils ont 35
ans trente trois ans on peut dire ils
sont encore à jour mais venir dire on va
sanctionner les parents pour moi c'est
pas c'est pas une bonne idée plutôt
trouver d autres alternatives
un enfant qui fait du mal c'est qu'il va
mal pour essayer de lui parler c'est de
comprendre et à son écoute
est ce que vous dites des enfants livrés
à eux mêmes est ce que justement
sanctionné les parents les
responsabiliser c'est pas leur envoyer
le message qu'il faut pas que leurs
enfants soient livrés à eux-mêmes
précisément c'est chercher un coupable
des forces pour noir pour ma part c'est
chercher un coupable des forces
absolument aujourd'hui il doit avoir
deux éducateurs l'état la république et
les lois aujourd'hui si vous savez qu'en
france c'est interdit de gifler un
enfant mais portait en fait c'est un
enfant nous envoyer et l'avons dit
d'être polis et derrière mon enfant
chose qui est vous attaquez parole je
veux le meilleur pour l'enfant pour mon
enfant comme tout chacun de nous on veut
le meilleur pour nos enfants permettait
justement permet de définir s'il vous
plaît arrêtez de finir et on veut tous
le meilleur pour nos parents pour nos
enfants et où tous les murs pour nos
enfants et au delà de ça devenait ou
punir les parents pour moi non plus à
trouver d autres alternatives
accompagnés des parents
l'état y prend 50 % les paroles prendre
5 1% c'est pas venir chercher un
coupable absolument non elle permettait
de la chesnaie ensuite elle vient me dit
il ya plusieurs choses agréables je suis
pas en accord
d'abord vous dit effectivement quand on
est dans certaines situations c'est
difficile bien sûr tout le monde le sait
mais il ya aussi des gens qui sont dans
des situations difficiles
je redis vous moi je suis député d'une
circonscription qu'il a plus pauvres
l'une des plus pauvres de france si ce
n'est la plus pauvre andorre la région
parisienne et des gens qui ont des
difficultés sociales de travail d'emploi
de santé j'en connais beaucoup et ils
élèvent pourtant fort honorablement leur
enfant il assume ce rôle d'éducateur
vous dit
le rôle d'éducateurs il doit être
confiée à l'état aux enseignants à
l'école mais pas seulement
moi je suis donné les parents doivent
partager non pas menons pas forcément
monsieur une obligation de résultat mais
une obligation de moyens au moins ils
ont au moins l'obligation de mettre
leurs enfants sur un chemin qu'on
appelle ou qu'on appelait encore un peu
pardonnez l'expression le droit chemin